good morning John it is our last video
of the 20 teams I'm tempted to look back
at fidgets spinners at the dress at
planking which was this decade
apparently but I can't because I'm too
worried about the future and I feel like
a lot of people are so I want to talk
about it and of course the future is
worrying it is unknown and unknowable
cause the thing that worried can get a
bad rap because we do it wrong so let's
talk about it but first in many ways the
world got better over the last 10 years
even if you just look at America the
I had a motorola droid in 2009 laughs
but also bigger deal gay marriage was
illegal also the unemployment rate went
from 10 percent down to 4 and yet to me
now feels a bit shaky er than then did
I'm not really sure why that is part of
it has to be that we're starting to feel
the real effects of climate change in
two different ways one the actual real
effects the climate is changing then
secondly we have a growing popular some
people knowing that they are gonna be
the ones who actually have to solve this
problem looking to their elected leaders
who aren't recognizing that the problem
exists so yeah that's gonna cause some
tension also this is an election year
and it's gonna be stressful because of
that they're always stressful and also
we just impeached our president about
the fact that he doesn't have a great
deal of respect for the process so yeah
I'm worried about that I'm also worried
that this tension some of which is
actively manufactured by our leaders or
just the architecture of the social
internet or by Russian bot farms will
continue to pull at the bonds of
community and that's a story of the last
decade but beyond that as well which has
had real negative impact so I just threw
a bunch of stuff at you I probably made
you feel super stressed out I apologize
for that but here's why there's somewhat
of a tendency to say like 2019 was such
a trash year there's no way 2020 could
be worse but like look I don't mean to
continue to freak you out but it could
always be worse this is one of the
reasons why I like science fiction it's
a way to worry about the future to like
play out scenarios in narrative form our
first life's library book of this year
parable of the sower by Octavia Butler
great example of this so I actually do
worry that we might worry the wrong ways
I also worry that we might not worry
enough so have fun with that but here's
what's up we're getting to the point one
of the smartest teachers I ever had once
told me that what he looks for and good
leaders is were people who are brave and
bold yes but also people who are kept up
at night by the possibilities who think
and ruminate and fret he says worry
isn't a disease it's a symptom of care
and it's a tool it's a survival strategy
ain't able to think through a situation
and assign probabilities to different
outcomes however flawed those
probabilities may be is a human
superpower it is the reason we are alive
right now
I don't think all worry is healthy or
anything we do have to find the right
ways to be worried in the right things
to worry about
we need worries that motivate us and
that are also based in reality rather
than ideology or just blind opposition
and also worry almost always works best
hand in hand with hosts oh yeah I'm
worried about 2020 because 2020 needs me
to be worried about it just like I need
my mom to be worried about me I know
that it can feel like we are powerless
in the face of so many other people who
want completely different or slightly
different things than we do and who
oftentimes have more resources than we
do we're not powerless who we donate to
who we vote for the conversations we
have how we choose to imagine the world
all of those things are how the entire
human earth gets built so yes I'm
worried for the future and yes I'm glad
John I'll see you in 2020 PS if you are
in st. Petersburg Atlanta or Raleigh
North Carolina and you want to come have
a good time and also maybe think some
big thoughts with us we're going on a
little tour more information in the
description